hey there chris well you know when you
drive around legion stadium right now
you see a whole lot of industrial
buildings commercial buildings take a
live look behind us here legion stadium
right there in the distance and right
here is a one of those industrial
buildings this one's actually for sale
well people in this area hope that
today's announcement will spark some
change
you could have quite an area for
tailgating ross fabrizio has this
building around the corner from alysia
stadium listed for sale the raiders made
it and of course the legion stadium gave
him an opportunity that he can move his
business elsewhere
he expects more businesses in this area
to do the same especially after
wednesday's super bowl announcement i
think he will see some transition that's
a really tight timeline this is a make
it happen kind of town allegiant stadium
is in county commissioner michael
knapp's district he says in june the
stadium district plan was approved to
transition this to a more pedestrian
friendly area with restaurants and
entertainment we continue to work with
business owners in the near and around
the area surrounding area who want to go
through a transition some of it is going
to happen naturally naf expects more
businesses to relocate as more buyers
come looking to take advantage of the
area lvcva ceo steve hill says the super
bowl could be what is needed to create
change 10 years ago that was largely a
warehouse district
but as more and more
events take place the makeup of the
surrounding areas is certainly going to
change fabrizio says on the same day of
the announcement he got a call about the
building restaurant bar brewery he sees
the potential for the area if they're
going to sell prior to 2024 then they're
probably probably looking at a premium
price
now back out here live fabrizio says a
lot of the concerns that many investors
and buyers have had with the buildings
around here is the parking but he does
expect more interest to pick up but
nafta also says the city that can do
this and get some change around here in
two years is las vegas reporting live
near religion stadium this evening joe
muller live local now